the Berlin science week is my favorite
week in Berlin
it's 10 days
showing what science has to offer
I've had a lot of people from geography
Neuroscience biology it's wonderful to
see so many enthusiastic People Under
One Roof talking about the wonderful
things science can do it's very
important to put all these super odd
questions how to break very is and make
science inclusive
[Music]
the Berlin science week is a great event
in which science has also to confront
its responsibility for dealing with the
challenges of this world
[Music]
that's really important that it's not
just the science way to communicate with
everyone but also to find other other
ways it's been a great opportunity to
share and of course being able to
interact with the audience we think it's
very important and interesting so let's
get engaged in direct conversation
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
we can actually get somewhere if we go
together in collaborations for me it's a
fantastic space to do though thank you
for doing science week for this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]